es tensa la situación que se vive aquí
en el municipio de necoclí en el
noroccidente de colombia kilómetros de
la frontera con panamá por el gran
represamiento de migrantes que están en
este lugar según las autoridades locales
son entre 10.000 y 15.000 personas las
que estarían aquí a la espera de poder
cruzar hacia el municipio vecino de
capurganá inicialmente se informó que
están represados aquí por las
condiciones meteorológicas que impedían
el cruce vía marítima sin embargo ese
tránsito ya se ha rehabilitado y pasan
entre 800 personas a diario sin embargo
también hay informes de que entran
diariamente hasta necoclí unas mil
personas encontramos aquí ciudadanos
haitianos sobre todo migrantes cubanos
migrantes venezolanos que están buscando
cruzar hacia el norte las autoridades
locales temen que las condiciones y la
gran cantidad de personas que están aquí
aumenten los casos de kobe 19 por lo que
decretaron el estado de calamidad
pública